All right.
Welcome back.
I hope you took a nice break there.
As you can see, I'm, well, I'm totally,
actually, it's, it's another decade and
I just kind of look the same.
So what we've done is we've laid
out sort of the general idea
of a Markov process, a Markov system,
and also a hidden Markov model.
And what I want to do now is talk about
sort of three computational problems
of hidden Markov models.
And then we'll talk just about a simple
application of this to, computer vision.
Also, just as a word of note,
I'm not going to go into the detail of
different parts of, of lots of the math,
just one part of it and
then the rest I'll, as they say,
I will leave it to the reader or
the viewer, as an exercise to go get,
schooled up in it.
Because, the details were less important
than knowing that it could be done and
then it was applied to computer vision.
All right so, we have a hidden Markov
model and we say that our hidden,
hidden Markov model is a lambda,
is a triplet of A, B, and pi
where A is the transition probability,
B your emission probabilities, and
pi was just the distribution
where things started.
Well given that, a HMM, given a machine,
there are three computational
problems we can look at.
And the first one is this.
Basically, given some
observation sequence, so
remember o1 through o cap T, are the
observed outputs, from 1 to cap T.
So that's a particular sequence.
You could ask what is the probability,
P of O, given that machine?
That is, what's the likelihood that
that machine generating that particular
sequence?
And this is really the classification,
recognition, it says problem but
actually how you use it for that, right?
Assume I've got a couple different
h m m's, maybe three of them, and
they each represent an activity.
And let's assume that the prior of
which activity is going on are equal.
All right?
So then, once I've,
if I have the priors are equal,
all I care about is the likelihood
of the data given the model.
And the HMM would allow me to evaluate
the likelihood of the observed
sequence for each of the given models.
Whichever one was highest,
that would be the one I picked.
That's a generative model
like we talked about before.
So the evaluation problem is,
substance the key problem at run time.
It's one we'll actually talk about.
Another problem is what's
called decoding the sequence.
So, remember you have
a sequence of observations, and
the question is,
what is the single most likely
sequence of states to have generated
that sequence of observations?
So, it's not all possible ways these
observations could generate, it's just
the single most likely sequence,
sometimes called the decoding problem.
And sometimes you care about that,
sometimes you don't.
When you do it basically
has to do with saying,
well if I, if the states have
some particular meaning to me.
Right?
Remember we talk about sunny, rainy,
cloudy, so you know they might
have some specific meaning.
I might want to say, okay here's what I
think the underlying state sequence, is,
actually sometimes in,
genome work, etcetera.
They actually want to know what
the underlying state sequence would be.
But if you are actually just
doing it for recognition,
then that's,
in some sense less important.
And then the third problem, is in some
sense the most complicated problem.
And that is, okay,
I give you a bunch of training examples,
a bunch of these O sequences.
Train model.
Learn the Lambda that and the way you,
that you learn is you pick the one
that maximizes the likelihood
of getting that observation.
It's a maximum likelihood, method.
It's actually called the EM,
Expectation Maximization,
and we'll talk about
that just a little bit.
We won't actually,
do the math of the, of that part.